Let's flip the script. Instead of asking
questions, today I'm going to answer
some. I'm Matt Abrahams, and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business. Welcome to
this Quick Thinks Ask Matt Anything
episode of Think Fast, Talk Smart the
podcast.
One of the many, many things I love
about our Think Fast, Talk Smart
learning community is interacting
[music]
with our members. I do this through
posts, comments, and discussions along
with our author talks and AMAs, Ask Matt
Anythings. Today I'm sharing a portion
of a recent learning community AMA.
Listen in [music] to learn about
authenticity, anxiety management, and
answering questions well. And consider
joining the learning community at
fastersmarter.io/learning
to ask your questions live. So, let's
jump right in.
Chris, what's your question, please?
Question, Matt. So, I do a lot of email
correspondence and and the nature of my
job is people are trying to sell me
things all the time. And there's one
introduction that people often use to an
email that I've I just don't like it and
I really try to avoid it. It's people
saying, "I hope you're doing well."
I know you understand what I'm talking
about, but I understand why it's there,
but it's soft language. It's an empty
gesture cuz it doesn't matter.
And so, I found myself when I compose an
email, I just skip anything like that
and go straight to business. What are
your thoughts on that and your
experience with that? It's funny that
you bring that up, Chris. So, Glenn
Kramon, who was one of our early guests,
he is a colleague of mine at the
business school. He teaches a course on
writing. He is an editor at the New York
Times. He has exactly the same pet
peeve. He does not like the superfluous
nature of that. And I agree, it's trite
now that people do it. However, I do
like the notion of trying to connect
first before jumping into an ask. I
think in some cases it can be a little
off-putting if you just jump in straight
away and say, "I need this." I think
other modes of communication are more
for that type of transactional get to
the point. I'm thinking of Slack or even
texting. Email to me feels slightly more
formal and that's why I like to start
with some kind of connection. I'll
perhaps say hello. I might comment on
the day. I might say, "I hope that that
your Tuesday is going well." I might
comment on something I know that the
person has done if I have some
connection with them. I might say, "You
know, how was your kids' basketball
game? I know the last time we spoke you
mentioned it." So, for me personally,
it's a little hard on email to jump
right in with the ask. That said, I
totally appreciate your point and using
something trite I think can be
difficult. Do you use it? Chris, I'm
going to put a question to you. Do you
use any kind of affectation or do you
just jump straight in?
I think I usually just say "I'd like to
share this with you." or "I was thinking
of you and this this is what I would
like to share with you." Excellent.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, so you do you do connect a little
bit. I mean, we have a lot of research.
We have a lot of research that says
connect first really helps. It builds
some warmth and relationship. Uh in an
email I think just as I I would say if a
phone call or a remote call like this,
there is some time that that I think
should be reserved for connecting first.
But something trite such as "Hope you
are well." is a bit much.
Uh other questions that you might have?
Hi, I'm Joffin. I'm from Germany. Oh,
welcome.
>> from India. Whenever I try to speak
something impromptu, it just seems like
I'm speaking too fast and then there is
this mess in my head that I'm trying to
string it through. So, do you have any
suggestions or any helpful tips that I
can follow?
Thank you for the question. So, Joffin,
you're asking when speaking, your brain
is working really fast. You're thinking
of a lot of things. And sometimes when
you end up speaking, then you end up
speaking fast. And how are there ways to
slow that down? So, there's several
things to do. First, we feel this
intense pressure in the moment, as you
mentioned, to respond right away. And we
don't have to. You can take a pause. You
can actually ask for it. You can say,
"Let me think about that for a moment."
Or perhaps you could ask a follow-on
question to get the other person
responding so you can collect your
thoughts. Or any of you who've listened
to the show know that I am a huge fan of
paraphrasing, extracting a key essence.
All three of those buy you a little bit
of time so that you can collect your
thoughts so you don't feel as rushed.
Because when we feel rushed, we begin to
think faster. We get a little nervous
and anxious. So, that's just giving
yourself time. Second, slowing yourself
down, taking a deep breath. When we get
very anxious, we breathe shallow. We
start thinking quickly and we speak
quickly. So, taking a deep breath slows
down the autonomic nervous system. Slows
down your breath rate so you'll speak
more slowly. And it can actually slow
down your thought process because you're
calming yourself down. Mentally, what I
encourage you to do when you get in
those moments is to think to yourself,
"What's the bottom line of what I want
to say?" Anchor yourself. A lot of us in
those moments, we think a lot of
thoughts all at once and it can get
jumbled and that jumbled nature makes us
think quicker cuz we're trying to figure
things out. Just say to yourself,
"What's the bottom line of my response?
What's the bottom line of my thought or
feeling?" Ground yourself there and then
build your response from that point. And
as you know, I'm a big fan of structure.
This might be where what, so what, now
what then comes in once I have bottom
line.
Then you are saying to slow down while
speaking. So, I I believe I am a fast
speaker and probably it's for the good
or maybe for the worst, but I feel
comfortable when I'm speaking fast. So,
do you have any ideas or suggestions how
I can really improve to slow down
speaking or am I really fighting against
my instinct?
Many of us speak faster than we want to
or in some cases should. Speaking
quickly boils down to breath. Your voice
is a wind instrument just like a flute,
a clarinet, a saxophone.
So, breath is really critical. So, there
are three things I recommend to people
to help slow down. First, breathe more
deeply. When you breathe deeply, you are
actually slowing down your speaking rate
because it just takes longer to do. When
I breathe shallow, I speak really
quickly because I'm breathing fast. So,
I So, when I take a deep breath, I slow
down. So, first, if you know you're
going into an interaction where you're
likely to speak quickly and you want to
speak slower, take a deep belly breath.
Second, gesture more slowly. I bet you
gesture quickly. Most people who speak
fast gesture fast. We sync up our
gesture rate and our speaking rate. So,
another thing you can do to slow
yourself down is to gesture more slowly.
The slower I gesture, the slower I
speak. So, low slow breathing, slower
gestures. And then the final bit of
advice is a mental idea which is imagine
that everyone you are speaking to is
non-native to the language you are
speaking.
So, if I believe everybody I'm talking
to is newer to the language that I'm
speaking, in my case English,
by nature, we tend to slow down. So,
breathe more slowly, deeper,
gesture more slowly, and remind yourself
that everybody you're speaking to is new
to the language you're speaking. And
those three things in some combination
will help slow down your speaking rate.
Hopefully, that was helpful.
Yulia, I'd love to hear your question,
please.
Thank you so much for having me here.
First, I'd like to thank you so much,
Matt, for the wisdom that you're
sharing. And my question is the
following. All of us have, by nature, we
have specific kind of way how we
communicate. Some of us are more
soft-spoken, some of us are more direct.
I believe that all communicators, all
good communicators, have to have a wide
repertoire or like tool that can be
applied in different occasions and with
different people. So, how can we develop
this ability to adapt to different
people who may not necessarily
appreciate our nature, the way we are?
What I hear in your question, Yulia, is
really talking about authenticity, who
we really are in our approach, and
thinking about the expectations that
others have. I will always argue that we
should be true to ourselves. Being
disingenuous,
faking it, that's not how we want to
come off. It doesn't feel good, and
often it can get us in trouble. That
said, there are certain expectations in
certain communication situations where
we might have to adjust and adapt. So,
some of you, for your work, for example,
have to speak in a very formal way,
giving presentations or in meetings. And
that might not be comfortable or what is
typical in your more conversational
approach. So, certainly, our
authenticity has to meet reality. I am
not saying to, again, be disingenuous,
but we have to be responsive. Our goal
is to serve the audiences that we speak
to. The single best thing you can do to
help understand and be authentic is to
take the time to really reflect on
what's important for you,
and where your strengths are and your
areas to strengthen. Every night before
I go to bed, I journal. And part of that
journaling is to reflect on something
that went well that day
in my communication and something that
I'd like to improve from that day. And
every Sunday I come back and look at
what I've written for the previous week
and make a plan for the subsequent week.
And I've been doing that for decades.
And that helps me to really not only
develop my skills but to really best
understand what's important to me in
communication and how I can lean into
those things.
Be authentic, understand what's
important to you and how you want to
show up so that you feel comfortable in
yourself doing that. But at the same
time, think about the expectations of
the situation and what would help. So
for example part of who I am is I I'm
very curious. So I like to ask lots of
questions. You all have heard me ask
lots of questions. But sometimes there's
situations where asking questions is not
what the circumstance or context
demands. And I need to adjust and adapt
while still staying true to my curiosity
and who I am. So it's first about
discovering what's important to you. The
reflection activity I do every evening
might help as part of that. And then
it's being aware of what's expected in
the situation and the context. Thank
you. I appreciate it, Matt.
Other questions that some of you might
have. Would love to to take one or two
more questions before I wrap things up.
I'm giving a talk for the Alzheimer's
Association which I do as a volunteer
and it's scripted. It's it's very has
these speaker notes and it's specific
information that they kind of stand by.
So I'm just kind of struggling with like
these speaker notes that are you know,
it's like I'm either reading it and so
I'm kind of struggling with
do I just stand in front of these people
and read it? There are times when all of
us have to communicate where
we are expected to say certain things.
Think of a company executive who because
of the media, because of investors needs
to say something exactly the right way
because they can get in trouble. I don't
think your situation is that defined,
but they do want you to get certain
information across. So, I would, as best
I could, if I were in your shoes, find a
way to integrate that information into a
way that's true and authentic for me
that's comfortable. So, maybe I don't
use every word that they say, but I get
the general idea across. And if you can
embed that in a truth for you, a story
that's relevant to you, an experience
that you've had, that makes it easier.
So, a way that I coach executives to
deal with the problem that you're
having. So, let's say their legal
department sends the paragraph, you have
to say, "This." I will have them read it
a couple times so they're familiar with
what it says. And then I'll say, "Put
the paragraph aside and just speak what
you remember of it." And as they're
doing that, we're recording it. And we
do it a couple times and we begin to see
their natural way of saying it. So,
they're not memorizing it. They're just
saying, "Here's the way they've
internalized it." And then they share
it. And then what we do from that is we
create bullet points. So, it's not a
paragraph, but we create a few bullet
points that are enough to trigger them
to help. What I do personally, what
works for me, and this might work for
you, Elizabeth, is I turn things into
questions. For some reason, my brain is
better able to remember content when I
remind myself that I'm answering a
question rather than relaying
information, even if the information is
the same. So, instead of saying, "I want
to cover these two points." I say, "I'm
going to answer these two questions."
And I frame it as a question that I am
answering. It takes some of the pressure
off. And for some reason, I am able to
get the information across in a more
clear, concise, and accurate way. So, my
two bits of advice to you in your
situation is to speak it out loud a
couple times reading it. And then record
yourself saying it without looking at
the manuscript. See where you land and
then create an outline from that. And
maybe also think, if somebody asked me
the question, what does this
organization do or how can you support
this organization? Just answer those
questions and see how close you come to
the manuscript they gave you. My hunch,
if you're like me, is you'll come pretty
close when you frame it as a question. I
hope there was something in there that
could be helpful. Yeah, absolutely.
Thanks. Excellent. I had a question,
something you did there with concluding
and saying like, any questions? I feel
like that's often done sort of a panic
stage of a presentation, where my mind
starts racing about if there are no
questions, how I'm going to kind of
ad-lib to fill up the awkward silence,
and then also fight off concerns like,
okay, are there not questions because
either I delivered something completely
nonsensical, or it was so dull that it
didn't prompt any questions. Yeah. And
then I think also the start of
presentations are the places where I
feel like I struggle the most, and of
course with the start it sort of sets
the tone for the rest of things to
follow. So, I'm curious about if you
have tips on that.
Many of us are most nervous when we
start a communication, be it a meeting,
a presentation, even a social
interaction. So, the advice I give to
people, one, is to get present and
collect your thoughts, deep breathing,
focusing on your goal. But, I also like
to have people distract their audiences.
Get them doing something so their
attention isn't just focused on you. How
do you do that? Well, you don't want the
distraction to be off-topic. Do
something that gets them engaged. So,
for example, take a poll. If you're in
front of a large group, how many of you
have Show a video clip. I work with a
very senior leader at a company you all
know. He's very nervous when he speaks,
especially at the beginning. So, all he
does is say, "Good morning, everyone.
Let's watch this video." And And has a
video clip that's very brief, and then
when the video's over, he just asks
people to comment on it. So, when you
take a poll, when you show a video, when
you put up a provocative image, slide,
whatever, you take people's attention
away from you, and if you immediately
ask a question on the response, then you
are in a different role. You're now a
facilitator, not a presenter. And for
many of us, we are much more comfortable
in that situation. So, I challenge all
of you to think about, how can I start
in a way that invites people to engage,
so their attention is not just on me,
it's on the activity, whatever that was.
So, that's how I recommend you start in
a way that can reduce some of that
awkwardness and nervousness. Now, on the
other side of the equation, when you go
to call for questions and there are no
questions, first you have to wait.
Pausing is appropriate. There are lots
of reasons people don't ask questions
right away. Maybe they're nervous and
they're trying to muster their courage.
Maybe they're thinking of their answer
or their question first. Maybe they're
just trying to see what types of
questions get asked. So, you have to
pause, and then if no questions come in,
ask yourself a question. I am a big fan
of what I call a back pocket question.
So, if nobody asks a question, I might
say, "A question I'm often asked is" So,
you see I'm about to ask myself a
question. Now, obviously, I should know
the answer to my question. That could
really be helpful to making sure that
the dead air is filled, and you'd be
amazed that when you answer that
question, how easily you get the second
question. So, it's all about getting
your audience engaged in some activity
up front, so it changes your role from
presenter to facilitator, and in the
end, you have to pause when you call for
questions, and then if no questions come
in, ask yourself a question. And just by
knowing that you have those tools, it
reduces your anxiety, because you know
you can handle both of those situations.
So, I encourage all of you to try one or
both of those in a lower stakes
situation, not a super high stakes one
to see the value, and that'll build
[music] your confidence even further.
Thank you for joining us for this Quick
Thinks Ask Matt Anything episode. To
join our next AMA live, sign up for our
Think Fast Talk Smart learning community
[music] at fastersmarter.io/learning.
This episode was produced [music] by
Katherine Reed, Ryan Campos, and me,
Matt Abrahams. Our music is from Floyd
Wonder. With thanks to Podium Podcast
Company. Please find us on YouTube and
wherever you get your podcasts. Be sure
to subscribe and rate us. Also, follow
us on LinkedIn, TikTok, and Instagram,
and check out fastersmarter.io
for deep dive videos, English language
learning content, and our newsletter.
Please consider our premium offering for
extended deep thinks episodes and much
more at fastersmarter.io/premium.
You'll also find value by joining our
Think Fast Talk Smart learning community
at fastersmarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, an AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's fastersmarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast Talk
Smart learning community.